foreign
with tear gas firecrackers and Bella
clouds they was not coming there to have
a good time
that's what I'm saying when I'm saying
there's something a little bit sick
about some of the people that are
showing up
you heard what happened with Carson yeah
I heard about that thing if you want to
wear Kyson that's uh probably the
largest twitch streamer at the moment
very popular very very popular person
and um he wanted to do a giveaway New
York and so essentially in the core of
the city he ended up running the
giveaway things got out of hand first it
started off about 300 fans and the crowd
grew to about 6 000 people fans started
weaving in and out of traffic sitting
off different types of explosive and
firecrackers as everything kind of lost
control
um police officers were sending in waves
of cops
so yeah this is when they scooped him
when before they arrested him they just
lifted him up
I don't care what nobody says if you
under five foot seven you can never let
another grown man pick you up like that
this really got this man in fetus
position being like you're going to jail
short people fight for your rights get
arrested with dignity and reportedly by
three it was already packed with the New
York Times reporting that the event was
held without a permit and things quickly
got out of hand when the crowd was
spilling into the streets blocking
pedestrians and cars While most in the
crowd were seemingly peaceful some just
got out of hand they saw people jumping
on cars banging them others throwing
objects like rocks fireworks were
probably going off at one point there's
no shortage of photos showing people
climbing onto things ozakai was in the
crowd at one point but then had to leave
local reports saying that he exited in
this car as people were literally
climbing on top of it as it was moving
at one point as the chaos is all
unfolding Kai posted about it on his
Instagram story writing that his fans
are amazing and telling him to be safe
but also ahead of this incident
according to the New York Post he told
his followers that they have a tendency
to go too wild and even saying depending
on how Rowdy things got the situation
might get shut down quickly but also
telling them we're gonna go crazy and so
with all this chaos we saw a slew of
rest being made and in fact Kai himself
got charged with first degree rioting
and citing a ride and unlawful assembly
in addition to the NYPD saying that 65
people were arrested 30 of which were
juveniles also with that footage of one
of the arrests went viral with police
seemingly grabbing a person and shoving
his face into a car window there were
also several other in injuries also with
all that the injury that's perhaps
getting the most attention is that of a
69 year old food vendor at his product
stolen amid all this apparently getting
hit in the process where did they hit
you sir
with people getting outraged at this
innocent guy just trying to do his job
got hurt and caught up in all this so
with that we saw political commentator
Hassan pie you're getting some backlash
for how he responded He was discussing
this whole thing and while watching a
clip about this vendor he said I
despise local media dude local media
talking about three dollars worth of
Doritos like you know there was a bank
run or with many finding that to be a
crude and insensitive or something after
you saw the old man it's like an old man
gets beaten up and that was his response
did a response it was also part of this
kind of larger criticism Hassan had of
local media's coverage of this so the
marketing that it played into the kind
of Boomer fear-mongering and saying that
it was racially biased I think Kai being
black and his uh audience being like
black as well also will factor into the
way that the media covers this you know
what I mean because people will
immediately be like oh this is gang
activity yeah they're Rowdy they're
Rowdy teenagers they're making it seem
like this is an organized crime ring the
one time you see like a bunch of black
teenagers around you're like oh my God
guys businesses are being loaded that
we've also seen other viral posts of
people pushing Back Against The
Narrative that this is like all racially
biased
foreign
will be here's the thing I think um a
lot of creators come into a lot of money
very quickly and don't know how to
manage it don't know how to act with it
um do I think Kai's gonna go to jail no
I don't think this charge is gonna stick
I think they're just doing this because
they have to set an example so they're
pushing for it and I understand why
because I agree they need to set an
example but here's the up thing
this was in a lot of ways really good
for Kai and his brand I gave him so much
visibility Free Press I mean worse comes
to work is getting a slap on the wrist
in my opinion and he's going to get some
of the best press you could ever imagine
people who are mainstream who've never
heard of this guy now a whole bunch of
new people are hearing about him and his
and so now he if he wants to drive money
brand deals different things like that
he's got a whole new level of pull so
the up thing is through the
destruction of property and all this
other that's happening this is
actually benefiting his career in a
tremendous way now I don't know kai he
may actually be really sad and
devastated by this whole thing and
doesn't want this kind of I'm just
saying if I'm like the pr firm or
whatever the it is I'm looking at
this like hey this is amazing we were
not even intending for it to be this big
and in a lot of ways it's like been very
good for him
so that's the business side of things
the other side of business things is
like if this is not what he intended
this is how it turned out he needs to
fire the pr people or his management or
whoever thought it was a good idea to
run an event like this because you
should see this kind of thing coming
from a mile away there are certain
creators who just can't go out to public
spaces and say all my fans come out and
not expect it to go kind of crazy you
gotta get some kind of new management
because there's no reason this should be
happening
considering the kind of pull y'all got
someone in your management should have
said no we're not going to do it like
that or yeah exactly or if you don't
have that kind of people Now's the Time
because you're at that point you are
at some point yes the biggest the
biggest of something else that meat
writing bro stop dick writing bro
just because you want a bit of cloud you
don't have to be out here giving all
these compliments just give the news
react and
how many more compliments gonna give
this I'm gonna do whatever the
I want
the is wrong with you
go
pause but go
you um Roger I didn't realize today
was going to be meat lovers day
I didn't realize we got salami on the
menu hey yeah I'm just hey you was oh
hey you the biggest the baddest I ever
had to chill out bro what the is
wrong with you hey that's what we all
heard go ahead just go ahead this is
like no meat lovers vegetarian only
let's go
maybe I'm jealous
[Laughter]
my are gonna compliment random
people but like yo we hit two million yo
get the out of here
let's go
oh
so I'll cut you off I apologize go ahead
nice you stupid no no you were saying
some real you're one of the biggest
baddest I've read
Hey listen that's where you stopped you
can keep going all right Best I Ever Had
you no I never said that
I don't even talk to you
stop that's you man that's not me Hey
listen uh you you're one of the best out
there and of something that is worldwide
everybody's gonna watch you you can't
just do random stuff like that you just
can't you're not you're not at that
level no more
you left that level a while ago okay you
can't just be like yeah meet and greet
Papa in the park is gonna be
it's gonna be crazy so yeah what's going
on nothing you got creamo I got cocoa
butter yeah stuff like that why my arms
shining I'm like yo this arm's not Sunny
why is this all right then I realized
hey there's something here and it's
smooth
best I ever had fun
all this to say yeah you know and I feel
like maybe I'm just so lucky I grew up
on Spider-Man but Uncle Ben's you know
with great responsibility comes great
power always comes back but a lot of
these people don't have a training they
don't have the wherewithal they don't
have the knowledge do they should they
know better I feel like a lot of people
think so and so he's got to hold a lot
of culpability for that but the truth is
a lot of these young kids who with their
Charisma and their personality start
drawing in all these viewers they don't
they don't
have set up to be able to make the right
decisions be it financially a lot of the
times or from a business standpoint or
from an event standpoint like this if
you don't have the right people in place
you're just gonna make mistakes so but I
think he intended for this no do I think
some of the videos make him look bad
absolutely what kind of beating you
getting for this oh nuclear
what no
I gotta go I gotta go I gotta go huh
stole a truck
with the open Edition they all ransacked
it what am I looking at this not on Kai
he didn't make these people do this they
had them in it before any of this
happened so I want to make sure that
conversation is not just centered on him
as an individual because there's a lot
of other people who need to be
accountable for their own actions I mean
on the official Channel there's a video
that's just wow that might if I if he's
going to court I would play this
look at this point look at them God
[Applause]
I don't think none of these people that
you see on the videos are PR people no
no
you know what I'm gonna say something
else too and this is probably where I
grew Julian I agree with him on the
management thing but this also too
you know one thing that's a big part of
the story
and people don't like saying it
including Hassan but it's
that's a part of this story yeah you
know
there's some to be said about the fact
that a lot of like young people and
especially black groups get together and
then it gets this violent and this Rowdy
you got people stealing whole ass food
trucks you got folks robbing old men
running through rental stores and
beating them up and like there's a
racial component or cultural component
to this that's very real that like
liberals never want to talk about
because it's like oh no it's all racism
and then right Wingers want to over
emphasize like it's the whole story or
there's some kind of genetic thing going
on there and it's like no but there's
some element of like cultural rowdiness
to this that is very I think it's
present in a lot of teenagers but is
especially present and I think in some
black teenagers and so I think that's a
part of their story but I think people
don't like saying it because they don't
want to appear whatever it is but I
don't know maybe y'all feel different
what do you think I think this the way
Society is is uh
designed it is meant for kids
for urban youth to be that way because
if you look at the if you listen to the
what the music that we listen to and
what is pushed out there for us has a
lot of rowdiness there's a lot of crazy
stuff that he'd be talking about what do
you mean I'll be playing drill when I'm
studying in the library
sure yeah I'd be yoga class with real
music if you've never heard of yoga
drill a lot of things that just pushes a
lot of violence a lot of rowdiness a lot
of riots and stuff like that they love
to push that he left to push that drug
he loves to push that Rowdy he has that
Riot that stuff like that they do that
they don't push like positive stuff and
things you know it's like the difference
between the tick tock that we have here
and The Tick Tock that I have in China
which is where Tick Tock is from so
I'm out
all blaming it on that but this is
definitely a part of it because like
there's a lot of other YouTubers who've
had big up meetups with fans and you
know a lot of them just didn't get give
on I think Dion brought up Mr Beast or
him running his first chain and how many
people showed up which was like over 10
20 000 people and it was very civil with
very little to no issues you know so
there has to be some element of that
that we look at and you know that a lot
of people brought up because you know we
talk about the effect of hip-hop on on
the youth and how it's influencing these
people be able to like get you know guns
and things like that and I think there's
an element of this that's real real
that's real and I don't for me it's sad
because there's so many other black
youth that were there that were saddened
by the fact you know I saw some videos
of some people saying like man that's
why we can't enjoy nothing that's why we
can't be having a good time and it's
true because you'll have groups of
people who are hexarati ruining it for
the other teenagers who just want to be
chill and simple
um to be what happened to Montreal we've
definitely had like waves of this kind
of stuff happening so it's sad because
not a bunch of kids got injured you got
people leaving with like complete
injuries bloody faces going to the
hospital and all this because we just
sometimes don't know how to act there
was no reason for this to get vile there
was no reason for this to go crazy you
want to just say it's teenagers but the
truth is this don't happen all the time
teenagers get together in large groups
so what's causing these kinds of issues
that's a part of the conversation I
think is much larger and a different one
but I think it is something that's real
so I just want to bring that up what
would you want to say no I never would
have some lesson anything else you want
to say about calling this whole thing no
I don't know the dude that much there's
something about like not having a lot of
things and stuff for Generation when you
see an opportunity to take you will and
that's that is what I think that can
come like just saying it it's just
I don't know why it's a bit
I feel like it's a bit
not disingenuous but
it's not the whole story it'll just be
like it's yeah okay but you have
to understand why
you have to understand where that's from
and you have to take that in account
like where it's from and why it's
happening when you keep when you've kept
people in the I'm not saying it's just
that and people don't have people don't
have uh responsibility in that they
absolutely do you have to be responsible
for your actions but when you deprive
someone and some people and a group of
people for so long of things they could
do
but I think that things like that might
happen no there's plenty of other
marginalized groups who don't engage in
this Behavior sorry I'm not going to use
the fact that somebody actually happened
in the past to say this is something
that could happen now this happens
because there's sick elements in our
culture today it has nothing to do with
the past and all that stuff it's what we
encourage these young people doing today
I think it's one and the other as the
past and you sprinkle that you put in
450 in the oven for 20 minutes and this
is what happens I don't think it's just
a thing that happens today but it's also
the things that happened in the past
generational your parents are going to
speak a certain way because certain
things happen to you and then you go
into that and then there's there's a
stuff that is implemented in your brain
right now uh socially that's gonna make
you act like that I think it's a bit of
both
all right
[Applause]
I didn't know where this was going
I'm just so disappointed it was going in
there but
it was going in her butt
it was going in her butt bro I mean
that's where it was going she got the
cheeks for that good for her I just
didn't see the coming I don't know why
the researcher put this in the
phone I didn't know where this
was going that was crazy
that that legitimate really shocked me I
don't know like
first off you have to think there was
like 30 whose hands went on that
football before she put it between her
cheeks
yeah
God bless you talk about Yeet she eat
that ball I'm talking about yeast bread
said a bunch of stuff that I actually
agreed with when you covered it but
there's one part that Gideon did that
made me laugh I want to play for you go
ahead I've been noticing something like
is it just like me or like are kids just
like different these days bro I'm out
with my girl last night right uh I saw
y'all boys I was like yo Dion and I'm
like yo I dap all them up I take a
picture with them there's like a group
of eight or ten of them right then there
was a dude inside of the uh of the
restaurant he worked there and he was
like yo Dion what's good my man I'm like
yo what's good bro how you doing and I
dap him up and then like he just looks
at me and he goes yo man I'm sorry but I
gotta do this and bro like just like
reaches from my head and he tries to
like take my do-rag off in front of my
girl
and I don't I've never met this man a
day in my life I literally just grab his
hand and like I just like put it back to
him and I'm like yo man we not about to
grab people that we don't know like that
and like
Brody was like dumbfound like
it was it was
I I don't know what it is but like like
bro what is it with people today bro
sorry I laughed pretty loud when I saw
this
huh what do you want me to say about
that
I'm just saying we fighting
I don't even care about that it's just
funny hearing it coming from Judea when
I see a YouTube prankster
I didn't know that part I didn't know
that part that he pranks people I don't
know I don't know gdm but he pranks
people yeah he does good friends though
he's like what is it with young people
these days but it's funny because I'm
looking at you and a lot of other
creators on these platforms and the way
that they go about doing stuff invading
other people's face really concerned
about like making their own content and
to be fair to Judean he's probably one
of the people who does it in a way I
really like but still you know it's like
what was done to you in a lot of ways is
what y'all be doing to other people if
not you it's a lot of the other pranks
y'all be defending so it's just funny to
me you were like yo kids you know things
but like they're seeing what you all do
and then they're replicating in a lot on
you I don't know what it is about these
kids uh making all these videos and
commenting on them I don't know what it
is like they all have opinions and stuff
are you trying to say that's what you do
true
[Music]
and I was like yo yo people already
stressed out financially just breaking
their cart on I don't know it's just
there's so much about this that's
sad and unnecessary
um well any any thoughts uh on on the
put that ball in their back so you see
that you see generational trauma
when you see oh yeah yeah when they're
breaking that car you see generational
trouble oh yes Martin Luther King
civil rights no come on bro
come on bro I mean MLK had a dream I
don't think it was none of that listen
these kids parents must also be having
dreams sleeping because
oh I'm raising some Savages I should
never be cut but yeah I digress I feel
like he's gonna fought some good
discussion so we want to hear from you
guys what do you guys think about this
whole situation do you believe Kai
should be punished very severely what do
you think should happen to understand
what about the individuals involved do
you feel like there's more to the story
and why these things went out ahead I
don't know I think when people want to
chalk it up to just teenagers being
teenagers I think we all know that's not
true I don't believe people believe that
it's just teenagers being teenagers but
we want to hear from you guys let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below uh